- Hi everyone Sal Khan here
from from Khan Academy .
Welcome to our daily homeroom which is
our way of staying in touch.
It started with with obviously
all the school closures and
social distancing with COVID.
But now it's really just evolved
into an interesting forum
to have good conversations
about education and other things.
Before we get into our conversation
with today's guests that I'm very excited
to be speaking to.
I will start with my
standard announcement,
or what I always say, which is a reminder
that Khan Academy is a not-for-profit
that we can only exist with
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to donate
please think about doing so.
I wanna give a special shout out
to several corporations that stepped-up
especially once they saw that we were
already running at a deficit pre-COVID.
And that our deficit had grown
in order to support the fact that
our traffic was 250, 300% normal,
and we're trying to accelerate
a whole bunch of programs
to keep everyone learning.
A special thanks to Bank of America,
Google.org, AT&T, fastly, and Novartis.
So, thanks to all of them,
but I do remind everyone,
we're still running at a deficit.
So if you're in a position to do so
please think about donating.
So with that, I'm really excited
to invite our guest Rachel Skiffer.
Rachel, there's many
ways to introduce you.
You are the Head of School
for my children's school.
That is one way.
You run Khan Lab School, which
I helped get off the ground,
but you really are doing
the real heavy lifting
you and the team there.
And also, I think you have
just a broad background
as an educator, you know you were
the Head of Strategy at Philips Andover,
for many years you've
worked in admissions,
you've worked as a lawyer, you've worked
as a strategy consultant.
So very broad background.
So Rachel, thank you,
thank you for joining us.
- Thank you for having me Sal.
- So a couple of, there's a bunch of stuff
you know when we originally scheduled
you know one of the things I thought
would be really interesting to talk
about is how (murmurs).
Well maybe a good place to start
just to ground us is explain to me
and to those watching you know,
why do you think a school
like Khan Lab School
needed to exist or what was interesting
about it to you that you know you wanted
to become the Head of School?
And then I'd love to go into how you've
been able to navigate the
COVID school closure situation?
And then also talk about a lot
of the the environment that
we're not finding ourselves in.
- Sure.
So there are lots of things that drew me
to Khan Lab School.
I would say, one of the things
that was the most important to me
was this underlying assumption
that all students could
achieve at a very high level.
And that because we give students
the space and time to
really master material,
without the outside pressure
of arbitrary letter grades,
allowing them a lot of autonomy
and the ability to work
with other students
and other teachers.
The motivation for our
students is really internal
it's not pressure from parents,
but really the kids are motivated
because they want to learn.
And I also think the year round model
for us is really exciting.
So even when parents are
interested in the school
and they ask a little bit about
our summer term and what that means,
and what the kids be sad,
that they don't have summer.
What I explained to them is,
school shouldn't be so bad for nine months
that students need summer as an escape.
But if school is really exciting
for the whole year
students are really excited
to come even during the summer
and it helps with things
like knowledge loss
and other things that happen when schools
are just closed for three months.
- And obviously I'm biased here,
but I can say as a
parent that it's strange
when it's a full day school.
So the school day ends at five or 6pm.
The kids don't wanna leave.
- They don't wanna leave.
- They don't like breaks (laughs).
- No they don't really
like it when they're sick,
we kinda have to say it's time to go,
but they try to pretend they're okay.
It's the opposite of probably what
some other schools have to deal with
when kids are malingering,
but our kids they love it.
- And what you know, what has been
I guess there's a couple like pre-COVID.
What has been, you know you kinda takeaway
have some of those beliefs
have been confirmed?
What's been difficult, but I think
given the world that we're
in a lot of educators
or a lot of places have struggled
with virtualization or
whatever school closures,
and then we're going into another
back to school season, which is also going
to be very uncertain.
What's your analysis of how KLS has fared
through this school closures?
What do you think y'all have done
that have worked out well,
and what are other learnings?
- So I think some of the things
that have worked out well, they've worked
out well because their processes
and practices that we've always had.
And so for instance, things
like student autonomy
for our youngest students,
say second graders,
third graders, they'll meet with a teacher
who's an advisor and they'll meet with
that person, once a week for 30 minutes
to map out their week.
What they're gonna study,
when they're gonna study,
when they're gonna spend
time on passionate projects.
But we really focus on
things like executive skills,
in addition to social emotional learning,
but really those skills
that are so important
when people leave school,
but that most schools
don't talk about or help
support students in developing.
So even though we are traditionally
a brick and mortar school, and right
we're not an online school naturally
just some of the technology that
our students use, and are also responsible
for in terms of handing in
work, tracking their progress.
When school moved from
the building to home.
A lot of our students,
even the younger ones again
had exercised that muscle
of planning out their work,
handing things in using
an electronic forum.
And so I think that's
been really beneficial
for our students.
And I think also for our older students
particularly our seniors, we have our
first graduating class coming up.
We didn't have to have a whole debate
about how are we gonna grade the students,
if they're not here.
We use a mastery based system, which means
that students can move forward
once they've mastered material.
And so what we say it's
effectively sort of a 90%,
of mastery of all the material
so that they don't have gaps.
So students are able to
focus on the learning
and not oh, is this B plus,
can I get it to an A minus
or you know, I'm just
not gonna show up anyway,
because I'm not doing well.
We allow students the space
to really achieve and do well.
- Right, right.
And I have to say, you
know what's interesting
for anyone if you visit the school,
what's unusual or what
people find it unusual
is you'll even see seven
and eight year olds,
who have a very clear
idea of what they need
to do at any given time.
And you know even though
it might be associated
with me or Khan Academy, a lot of ways
it's not a technology focused school,
it's about student
agency and collaboration
and human interaction.
So you see these kids being able
to take that agency and I know there's
a question from YouTube
Adnan Abbas Kanchwala
about, you know why do you need a KLS,
if you have things like Khan Academy
that kids could use whenever they want?
And I'll actually take a stab at that
the logic behind founding Khan Academy was
sorry founding Khan Lab School
is that Khan Academy exists, and hopefully
you can scale and empower
hundreds of millions
or billions of folks.
But the existence of
tools like Khan Academy
allows us to re-imagine what the
actual school day or school
structure could look like.
And so some of the things
that Rachel talked about,
you know why do we have to
take off during summers?
Why can we go all year round?
Can't we get to a competency based model?
Can't we create a world where
the students teach each other,
where faculty are able to co-teach,
where they're able to do
one-on-one smaller group sessions.
And so the whole point of
it and why it's a Lab School
is so that it can explore these
and eventually share with the world.
And I have to say, Rachel you know
you and the team at Khan
Lab School as a parent,
it has been amazing how
seamless it has been.
But, and I think to a large degree,
because it is y'all have been reinforcing
these ideas of student autonomy agency,
and these really personal connections
between the teachers and the students,
which I think is super powerful.
One question, you know
there's a bunch of questions
people are asking about
this coming school year.
- Right.
- You know, what do you think
is gonna happen broadly,
to just someone who observes
the education space?
I know, you talk to a
lot of heads of schools
around the country and principals,
and how are y'all thinking about it?
- So we're doing a lot of
scenario planning, right?
And so we are the sort of the scenario
where everything goes back to normal
and we're all in the building
as we were before, which
is really put on the shelf,
'cause that's not likely to happen.
And so now we're thinking about
where our students are
developmentally where a K to 12.
So what do our new five year olds,
our kindergarteners,
what are they gonna need?
And what kind of support
as students move up
through that chain through senior year?
How much time if we're able to
can they spend on campus?
And then how do we do some
of that teaching remotely?
And I like to go back
to the earlier question
about sort of, why do you
need a Khan Lab School,
and it's just because
learning is relational, right?
And when as students develop, they move
from this mode to building
a foundation, right?
Learning how to learn habits of mind,
but content is important.
And even though there are a lot of things
that are at a student's fingertips.
It's much easier to grow
in your math development,
if there are things like
times tables that you know,
and you can recall instead of having
to look those up every
time you have a question.
And so the same way, if I just put a piano
in a kid's house, you
know it's actually helpful
for them to have someone
with a deep expertise,
who knows kids well, to really teach them
and build scaffolding.
And so the students practice and
then they're eventually able
to learn pieces on their own.
So I think what we've discovered,
even though everyone is in their own home
or apartment learning is that it's
the community piece that's really helped.
And the fact that we know
our students really well,
we've had enough time to check in not only
with our teachers, but with our families,
to see who had the necessary technology
and internet connections
at home and who didn't,
so that we could make sure that everyone
had what they needed by the time
sort of school went remote.
So for the fall, we're doing a mix of
sort of health and wellness and
what the County of Santa
Clara is telling us
as possible in terms
of physical distancing,
masks, things like that.
And then we're also thinking about,
where our students are in terms of
what they're able to do on their own.
And then we're also thinking about
the social aspects because even you know,
the most brilliant student who probably
doesn't need teachers anymore.
Even though they're really helpful
to help us teach other students
you still need that social aspect.
There's still so much about growing up
that is about learning how
to assist with other people
and negotiate and the
moments in between classes
there's as much value in there I think
for students as what
they're learning in class.
So to get to your questions Sal.
I think we're looking at
sort of a hybrid model
of having students at
home, having students
come to campus when possible, and thinking
about how to make that
as seamless as possible.
So we'll see.
- And one thing that
actually, we should find time
to brainstorm on and more,
but I'm excited about it
'cause even when we started
KLS, I was hoping that
a lot of the school day
could happen outside
but now we have a
epidemiological reason for that.
(murmurs) just a tree and a hotspot.
(both laugh)
And you know it's, people don't realize
the word Academy actually
comes from a field
where Plato used to teach
or have Socratic dialogues outside,
and then it became his Akadēmos.
I'm a big fan especially
if the weather's good.
Even if the weather's bad frankly,
I think it builds character.
- You know, the kids are tough.
They can handle it.
It's California.
We'll be fine.
- That's right.
And even if it's not California,
it's you know, we're
meant to be in nature.
- Right.
- So and there were a
ton of questions here
about the education model.
But I do wanna actually
broaden our conversation
because I think there's another obviously,
what's been happening
with Black Lives Matter,
with the George Floyd murder.
And what I found your
letter to the community,
I thought was, it was reflective,
and it gave justice to
the moment we're in.
But it was also I found
almost strangely hopeful
and had a silver lining to it.
So I guess one question that I think
a lot of folks are struggling with
especially parents of young kids are,
how do we talk about what's
going on in the world?
Well, how do we talk
about police brutality,
racism in this moment?
- You know, that's an
interesting question.
I have preschoolers and
so the the conversation
I have not as an educator, but as a parent
with my husband is sort of
what do they already know?
And how can we best support them?
So I'd say for us as an
African American family
one of the things that we make sure of
is that in terms of the books
that we have in the house,
that my kids see themselves
represented, right?
And it's not necessarily books
about the civil rights movement,
or you know people who broke barriers,
but also about kids in
Central Park hanging out
with a Dinosaur, right?
Or kids who bring a Lion to the library.
But there's something about, and educators
talk a lot about mirrors and windows.
And so there's a part of the population
where they see themselves mirrored
in everything, right?
TV shows, games, the books that they have.
And then there's some kids
that only have windows.
They're very good at
understanding cultures
that are different than theirs
particularly if they're
not in the majority,
but they don't see a lot of mirrors.
And so for us in terms
of sort of building up
our kids self worth, it's really
about making sure they
have as many mirrors
as possible in their day to
day lives, including schools.
So you know what books
are in the school library
and what does the student
population look like.
For older students.
If I can put my educator hat back on,
there've been so many
book lists going around
for parents to read, older students
to read along with them.
"Stamped" is a great book
that I would recommend.
"The New Jim Crow" has
a young readers edition
and also a teacher's guide.
But I also think, one it's important
whether you're a parent or a teacher,
when you're having conversations
the point isn't to
necessarily re-traumatize
particularly your Black
and Brown students.
So if you're a history teacher,
and you're talking about Emmett Till
you don't necessarily have to show
the picture of him in the coffin, right?
Our humanity is not in our death.
But you can have a picture of him
when he was alive, a vibrant young man.
And the same thing with
the books that are read.
I think there's a lot
about American history
that people in the U.S. don't know.
So, for parents, what do you know
about reconstruction at the time when
African-Americans were governors
and senators (murmurs) towns
in addition to understanding things
like the Tulsa race massacre.
So it would be I think disrespectful,
for me to at this point lack hope,
just in thinking about allowing the work
of the people who came before me
even in my family, my
grandparents, my parents,
and so for now I'm hopeful but I know
that people have to do work.
Another good book "The
Condemnation of Blackness"
I think everyone has to check sort
of their underlying
presumptions about people.
And the one of the things that brings me
the most hope is just looking at
the people who are
demonstrating and protesting.
It's some of the most multicultural
and I think there are a lot
of coalition's being built.
So just the people who are
in the street protesting
police brutality really
focused on Anti-racism.
It's probably the most diverse group
of people that this country has ever seen.
And it's happening around the world.
- Yeah.
And what's your advice?
You know, this is something
I'm struggling at home
especially the younger
kids, you know all my kids
but you know Azad and Diya who are five
and almost nine years old.
You know they know something's going on
and they're curious they
might even have seen
some of the footage of you know,
I hope they haven't seen the footage
of the George Floyd murder
but you know how do
you, 'cause there's one
of this the graphic nature of some of it,
(murmurs)
at some age, maybe they should see it.
But then there's also a question of
you know for some of
them, they're just like,
wait this makes no sense at all.
Like why should anyone be you know,
based on their skin, it just doesn't grok
with their head and
you're almost introducing
the idea of racism to them.
- I mean, I think the reality is
that even though, they're young kids
and young kids have a very well
developed sense of justice.
They know it's not fair we still live,
in this country, right?
So there are things that
are just there in the walls.
They're systemic, that we don't question.
But that still color how
we interact with people.
So when one of the conversations or
if you wanna talk to your kid about it
is just to ask them what they know,
what have they heard?
And I think people would be surprised
by how much their children have picked up.
If they haven't actively
had these conversations
in the house.
Just you know kids are
smart, and they get by
with a lot of things because
they know how to listen.
And so I think that you can't assume
that kids don't see color, right?
One is 'cause they don't.
But two there are a lot of studies
that say even when kids
are babies they do.
So then the question is, is the difference
a bad thing or a good thing?
And so those are the kind of conversations
that you can have.
And I think there's also the conversation
about even sort of the
most innocuous things
that people assume about
different groups of people.
So can you have that
conversation and be brave?
And have you done enough work and study
as a parent to be able to answer
some of those questions and even questions
some of those assumptions yourself.
It's not easy, right?
I did some professional development
once with someone who said that
sort of Anti-racism work, it's like going
to the dentist, right?
It's not one and done.
You gotta flush, you
gotta brush in between
and every once in a while you gotta go in
and get a deep cleaning.
So it's something you
have to be conscious about
and deliberate about.
Because if you're not, then you just slip
into to bad habits and old habits.
- Yeah, that's super helpful.
But it's obviously yes.
It's not easy and it's very nuanced.
There are some questions.
And these conversations go so fast
when we're talking about
interesting topics.
There are some definitely some questions.
Let's see, Marshmello
from YouTube is asking,
and maybe we can, you know broaden this,
how will COVID evolutionize learning?
I don't think we will be
very normal very soon.
And what's the new normal?
So I guess maybe to
paraphrase this question,
there's a stuff that you're
doing the immediate term to,
you know make sure that
everything is working,
so to speak and back to school,
but how do you think this is
going to change education?
Well one at KLS maybe
in a more permanent way
even post-COVID.
Or what implications do you think
it might have broadly,
you know well beyond KLS
in the system as a whole.
And maybe I'll even add, you know
what's going on with the
protests Black Lives Matter,
do you think that's also going
to have some impact on curricular
or things like that, but COVID,
both of these things that
are going on in the world?
- So I would say in terms
of what is COVID doing,
I think it's shining a
light on how unprepared
we are for change.
And I also think it shines a light
on how incredibly creative
teachers can be in a moment.
But that calls for a lot of support.
And not just putting a laptop or an iPad
and a teacher's hand or a student's hand,
but what kind of real training
that's best led by teachers and teachers
who are really excited
about this kind of teaching,
and that they can work
with their peer group
and their colleagues.
I also think all of this shines a light
on the fact that the teaching actually
should follow the student where they are.
And so giving less weight to just how long
has a student sat in a class,
but more what have they
actually learned in that class?
And is it okay for them to
take a little bit longer
to make sure they master the material,
then to make sure that just you know
things are running on
time and if you don't
get it too bad kid, we have
to move to the next thing.
Like is that the point?
So, at Khan Lab School you know
we always say that we're here
to educate and not to sort.
And again, I think the underlying belief
that all students can achieve at a
really high level is somewhat radical.
There's good research to say that
when you're able to combine
mastery based learning,
where the goal for kids
is to actually understand
the material versus getting a grade.
And you're able to do
some kind of one-on-one time
not tutoring necessarily
but even sort of tools like Khan Academy
are incredible for kids
to shore up their skills,
that just the achievement is incredible.
So I think I'm really having belief
in all kids and allowing
more space and time.
And I'd say also, there
are probably millions
of parents across this nation who have
a deeper appreciation for
teachers and what they do,
because it's hard.
Whether you're teaching
someone how to read
or whether you're teaching someone
about socks or something like that.
It's all really difficult and it's about
making sure that the motivation
for students is internal.
Because we do a lot of hoop
jumping, I think these days.
- Yeah completely agree.
And you know, my own take is exactly
what you're saying is I think
there's a world where
post-COVID the whole system
you know, this hybrid environment we're in
it is actually, it's
making a lot of educators,
a lot of systems have to
think a little bit more
in the direction that y'all have already
been thinking at KLS which
is, how do we give students
more agency but at the same time
give them constraints and accountability,
so that they are able to add supports,
with teachers but you know, rethinking.
Okay, is lecture the best thing
or is it better for that teacher time
to be more in small group
focused interventions
or one on one sessions and you know
goal reflections and things like that,
and I have to say, you
know I've been bragging
maybe more than I should because obviously
my name is associated with the school,
so it probably doesn't reflect well on me.
But y'all have done an incredible job.
Being able to fluidly go between these,
you know in person
world, and this you know
socially distance world, I think can be
a really good example for what
could be done other places.
Rachel, unfortunately, we're out of time.
I hope we can do this
again in the near future,
'cause there's a ton of questions
that I didn't even get to.
I will just say, you know
I get a an undue amount
of credit for both Khan Academy
and for Khan lab school,
because of, I guess
there's a name association.
- I do.
(Khan laughs)
- But Rachel is one of
the people in my life,
who's really you know, doing the real
on the groundwork of
driving this broader vision
and this broader mission forward.
And so I feel very lucky to work with her,
not just as the Head of School
of my children's school, which I do feel
very fortunate about, but also you know
really pushing forward these ideas
of what school could be not
just for the 200 students
at KLS but what they
could be for the you know
a billion and a half kids
around the world one day.
So thank you Rachel for that.
- Sure.
Thank you for having me.
It's a pleasure to to be
your child's Head of School
your children's Head of School.
Next time we can talk about synchronous
versus asynchronous learning.
I'm sure you got some of those questions.
But I think it's a great
time for education.
And I think, as a country, we're poised
to have some fundamental change
for the better of all of us.
- Actually not to, you know we
had a nice conclusion going,
but since you brought up
asynchronous and synchronous,
'cause there are several
questions about that.
How do you structure?
I mean, how are you thinking about
asynchronous and synchronous
just to (murmurs).
- We're doing both.
I think initially, when everyone had
to shelter in place the instinct was
to sort of take what you
were doing in the building,
and then just map it
to an online platform.
And it just doesn't work.
Even for the teachers, the students
you have to to move
your body a little bit.
So then the conversation is, what is great
for students to be able to do together?
What are the conversations
that they can have?
And then what are those moments
where they can actually
do some work on their own?
And it's actually better for them
to have some space for
flow and for deep thinking.
So for us we are doing both
from kindergarten all the
way through 12th grade.
And our teachers are incredibly
thoughtful and creative.
And even when I look at sessions
for the kindergarteners,
they're actually engaged.
But I think part of it is that
in those moments they're being
asked to interact, right?
It's not just our
teachers talking to them,
but they're asking them questions.
They're asking the
students to work together.
And so that happens in math classes,
english classes, history
classes, science classes.
So I think you need both and I think just
by virtue of it being online,
it can't be as full a day,
as we're used to students having
when they're in person,
just because they need
those breaks.
But it doesn't mean they're learning less.
If the system that you
have in place works,
and if anything it's teaching them again
those executive skills,
time management planning,
that are really gonna
serve them beyond school.
- Now and this is one of the areas
you know one of the dreams of KLS
is that it can really work in
symbiosis with Khan Academy.
And, you know one of the things
that I'm excited about
exploring with Rachel
and the team at KLS over the
next couple of months are,
you know a lot of these practices
that Rachel and KLS team have developed
can we help document some of that?
Because the whole world is trying
to answer these questions right now.
And so thanks Rachel and the team
for really I think doing a
really amazing job right now.
And, you know thanks for
being guests right now.
- Sure thanks for the support Sal.
Thanks.
- Thanks Rachel.
So thanks, everyone for joining us.
As you can see, I'm usually lucky
in getting people to
show up for this thing
and having interesting conversations
and the time always seems
to go a little bit faster
than I expect and my apologies
to all of the questions
that I did not get to,
but I'm sure we'll be able to
get Rachel on in the future.
But for everyone watching
thanks for watching,
and I remind you if you're in a position
to do so please think about
donating to Khan Academy
but I will see you tomorrow.